Ah, food, one of life’s great pleasures.
Whether you’re an organism whose body can
create its own food, or you make do with the
consumption of other organisms, food sustains
and connects life both large and small.
But we’re not going to talk about food today.
We’re going to talk about what happens…after.
No great meal comes without consequences.
Even photosynthetic microbes produce oxygen
they don’t need, a byproduct that is quite
useful to many other organisms, including
us.
And for organisms that have to digest their
food to extract nutrients, well, there’s
all sorts of stuff left behind when the process
is done.
In the world of the microcosmos, there are
not only many varied tiny organisms.
There are also many varied ways to produce
even tinier poop.
And when we say “tinier,” we mean it.
If you’re worried about being grossed out
by this video, or you really want to make
sure you’re not missing anything, just know
that some of this pooping will require you
to pay very close attention.
Some of this will probably look similar to
macroscopic bowel movements, and some will
seem less so.
So let’s start with the more poop-like poop
that comes from some of the multicellular
members of the microcosmos, particularly the
ones with digestive systems complete with
specialized regions for digesting food and
releasing solid waste.
Our dragon-like friend the gastrotrich is
doing the old scrunch-and-poop, probably after
having finished a nice meal made up of bacteria
or protozoa.
The food came in through its pharynx and was
then sent through the intestine, a straight
tube full of digestive cells.
After, the remains continued their way to
the end of the tube, where lies the anus--a
microscopic gateway out of the gastrotrich
and into the world.
That’s all well and good for the more complex
organisms, but how does one poop when one
does not have a butthole?
Well, for some single-celled organisms, one
becomes the butthole.
Such is the case for amoebas.
Their formlessness allows them to easily shift
their shape around to take in food via phagocytosis.
The amoeba here happens to have found a nice
meal made of a ciliate, which is now contained
in a food vacuole filling with digestive enzymes.
Those enzymes will eventually break the ciliate
down, allowing the amoeba to absorb nutrients
into its cytoplasm.
But then what happens with the remains?
Well, as we see with this amoeba here, it
gets released.
Amoebas and other similar organisms use a
process called exocytosis to send waste back
to the membrane where it is removed from their
body.
You can see it again here in this Mastigamoeba,
slowly gliding along the microscope slide
while a round bit seems to come off up top.
It almost looks like it’s leaving behind
a little piece of itself, which I mean, maybe it is.
Ciliates have a more refined approach to pooping,
which is to say they have the unicellular
equivalent of an anus called the cytoproct.
Ciliates gather food into an oral groove,
and then consume it in the digestive vacuoles
that travel through the cell.
Eventually, when the vacuole makes its way
to the cytoproct, the contents get out, and
there you have ciliate poop.
The way organisms poop—the way microbes
poop—are even more varied and wonderful
than we’ve been able to show you here.
But you might be wondering how you even get
from something relatively simple like this
ciliate releasing a small bit of waste to
something more complex, like this tardigrade
with its more compartmentalized approach to
defecation.
Well the answer, of course, is evolution,
but it’s an answer that leads to many more
unanswered questions.
Even within animals, the evolution of the
anus—or in some species, the cloaca—is
not well understood, as discussed in a 2015
review paper with the spectacular title, “Getting
to the bottom of anal evolution”.
While the anus itself is linked to the evolution
of a digestive system, not all metazoans have
a designated anus.
The hydra gut has only one opening, which
means that the organism’s mouth has to pull
digestive double duty and open back up to
release the waste.
And how that system fits in with the evolution
of digestion overall is unclear.
Much like the evolution of sex, anuses are
a trait that appears and disappears in evolutionary
lineages, reflecting the fact that they might
be useful for some animals and less so for others.
The duality of the hydra’s mouth seems to
be working out great for them after all.
But having a digestive system with a distinct
entrance and exit is pretty handy too.
For one, it’s just a little less disgusting.
But it also keeps food flowing in one direction.
And that means animals like the tardigrade
and us don’t have to wait to finish digesting
to eat more food.
That would be annoying.
We just get to keep eating, all thanks to
that evolutionary mystery that is the anus.
In the end though, anus or not, everybody
poops.
Food, after all, might be one of life’s
great pleasures, but all good things must
come to an end.
And perhaps, with the microcosmos, we can
find some pleasure in that as well.
Thank you for coming on this journey with
us as we explore the unseen world that surrounds us.
It’s been quite awhile since we did a video
answering some of your most frequently asked
questions, so we would like to let you know
that we’re going to be doing another one
of those soon.
If you have any questions that you’d like
us to answer in that video, please leave them
in the comments, or you can tweet us your
questions @journeytomicro or leave them for
us on our Patreon.
And yes, all of the people on the screen right
now, those are our patrons.
They are the people that make this show possible.
So, if you want to be one of them you can
go to patreon.com/journeytomicro.
If you want to see more from our Master of
Microscopes James Weiss, check out Jam & Germs
on Instagram, and if you want to see more
from us, there’s probably a subscribe button
somewhere nearby.